l'église pendant des années alors je
pense d'abord n'a pas pris la mesure de
ce qui était qu'une agressions sexuelles
sur enfants et pendant des années on a
finalement beaucoup banalisée ça alors
il ya eu plusieurs mouvements de
libération de la parole sur ses terres
en amérique du nord c'est plutôt là où
l'église résister où elle a été obligée
de se confronter à ses responsabilités
oui mais fois même en france la question
de la reconnaissance des violences
sexuels sur les mineurs explosant
églises ou ailleurs elle a eu plusieurs
phases il ya eu les années 80 et puis on
a reçu un peu ce phénomène pour en
désigner comme coupable des pédophiles
extrafamilial le grand méchant loup qui
pourrait nous permettre de penser qu'il
n'y avait rien à voir dans nos
institutions ou dans ce qu'on
connaissait enfin c'était pas nous qui
étions responsables de ça et puis à
nouveau là il ya quelque chose qui se
parlent en notre société autour de de
ces faits mais bien sûr que ces
institutions d'abord ne mesurait pas la
gravité de ces choses-là très clair et
puis et puis qu'elle couvrait parfois
par
volonté de pas de cachet finalement de
ne pas éviter le scandale et puis dans
une forme de banalisation et en ce cas
était dit tout à l'heure justement la
position de toute puissance et 2 et 2
finalement de d'exemplarité du prêtre
leur a été décoré corner à cause de ça
et finalement on a couvert beaucoup de
choses
[Musique]